merci beaucoup Jonathan Rumi merci
d'être d'être avec nous je parlais de
cette série Chen qui est un un phénomène
mondial qui parle de la vie de Jésus les
chiffres donnent le tourn ils vont
s'afficher sur sur votre
écran les épisodes ont été visionné plus
de 600 millions de fois dans
179 pays voilà les trois premières
saisons seront bientôt doublé dans 50
langues il est prévu de les soustitrer
dans plus de 600 langues c'est un V
phénomène et et votre parcours est
absolument incroyable la saison 3 vous
serez demain au Grand Rex à Paris pour
la diffusion des deux premiers épisodes
de la saison 3 la saison 4 est déjà en
en tournage au Grand Rex donc demain ça
va diffusé dans 150 cinémas en France he
c'est ça absolument c'est 8 octobre et
c'est vrai que les chiffres sont
faramineux parce que ça a fait un
meilleur démarrage qu'Avatar lors du
premier jour d'exploitation en salle aux
États-Unis c'est dire à quel point cette
série est un véritable phénomène mondial
alors on va peut-être d'abord voir des
images de la série pour ceux qui la
connaissent pas et bien moi je vous dis
aimez vos ennemis et Prz pour ceux qui
vous persécutent je me sens pas
différent vous n'avez pas à sentir quoi
que ce soit pour accomplir de grandes
choses Jésus si tu ne renonces pas au
paroles que tu viens de prononcer nous
naurons pas d'autre choix que de suivre
la loi de Moïse je suis la loi de Moïse
j incarn Jésus c'est quand même un rôle
qui n'est pas courant comment comment ça
s'est présenté à
vous je dois remercier
Dieu cel faisait ans acteur à Los
Angeles et 10 ans avant ça à New
York le réalisateur de la série avait
déjà fait quelques petit courtmétrage
quelques années
auparavant et on on s'est bien
entendu et il m'a demandé de venir faire
cette série et bien sûr j'ai dit oui je
suis un acteur j'avais besoin de
travailler vous avez besoin de
travailler alors vous êtes catholique
vous êtes catholique vous avez la foi
parce que incn
incarner ce rôle c'est c'est il faut
pouvoir effectivement donner de sa
personne vous savez le rôle devient bien
plus authentique le personnage devient
beaucoup plus authentique si les gens
ressente un certain lien entre vous et
ce
personnag pour moi la foi a toujours
fait partie de ma vie depuis petit déjà
et en particulier lorsque j'étais
confronté à des difficultés dans ma
profession en tant qu'acteur je me suis
réellement
mais comment vous vous êtes préparé
physiquement mentalement pour pour
incarner ce
rôle alors pour ce rôle ça demandé
beaucoup de foi beaucoup de
prière beaucoup de recherche
également et beaucoup
d'engagement il fallait que je réussisse
à m'ffacer pouriss au message du
personnage et j'ai dû laisser l'esprit
travailler à travers moi Isabelle alors
stup do like French Voice vous aimez
votre voix
française
fraise je je parle le français
couramment quand on entend ma voix
française c'est vrai quand on regarde
cette série on a vraiment l'impression
d'être dans un autre monde c'est une
véritable faille spatioemporelle cette
série elle a été tournée où au juste et
est-ce que vous avez étonné été étonné
vous-même de la façon dont vous avez été
habillé maquillé la façon dont une
région toute entière finalement a été
transformée le tournage a lieu à deux
endroits dans le Uta et au
Texas et c'est comme ça qu'on a pu
recréer l'Israël du 1er siècle il y a
beaucoup d'artistes et d'artisans entre
guillemets qui ont réussi à transformer
ces lieux ces régions aux États-Unis
pour que on ait l'impression qu'on soit
en Israël au MoyenOrient au 1er siècle
Jonathan je voudrais que vous racontiez
à ceux qui nous regardent comment ce
rôle est venu à vous moi j'ai écoutter
vos vos interviews ça se passe dans un
moment très particulier de de votre vie
vous avez peut-être eu un peu le
sentiment que c'était un cadeau qui vous
était offert est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter comment ça se
passe oui alors je venais de déménager à
Los Angeles en
2010 je travaillais beaucoup côté
production de film et de séries
d'émission de télé je cherchais des
emplacements des des lieux donc je suis
parti à Los Angeles parce que j'ai
ressenti ce désir ce besoin de suivre la
vie d'un
artiste j'ai senti cet appel cet appel
vers lesarts en particulier en tant que
actcteur et donc pendant 8 ans j'ai eu
une vie un peu difficile j'ai quitté mon
emploi quotidien entre guillemets et
j'ai eu du mal à trouver un travail
régulier et je suis arrivé à un moment
où je n'avais plus d'argent je n'avais
plus de travail tous ces petits boulots
que je faisais j'ai travaillé comme
cuisinier chauffeur et tout a tout s'est
asséché tout a disparu et au bout d'un
moment et bien je n'avais plus assez à
manger j'avais des têtes j'avais plus
d'argent plus d'entrée d'argent non
plus je me suis donc agenouillé j'ai
prié et dit seigneur si c'est ce que tu
veux que je fasse j'ai besoin d'un coup
de main il faut que tu interviennes et
que tu me montres que je suis sur la
bonne voie parce que sinon je ne sais
pas ce que je vais pouvoir
faire je suis sorti j'avais environ 20
dollars dans la
poche ce matin je m'étais
réveillé j'étais à découvert de 80
dollars et je me suis dit bon ben voilà
je lâche prise si tu veux que je quitte
cette profession pas de problème je me
remets à toi j'ai je suis sorti j'ai
pris un bon repas et je suis rentré dans
mon appartement j'ai ouvert ma boîte aux
lettres et il y avait quatre chèqus qui
m'attendaient et je ne savais pas du
tout d'où il venaient alors je les ai
ouverts chaque chèque était plus grand
que celui
d'avant et là j'avais 1100
dollars et je me suis dit bon ça c'est
nouveau ça c'est nouveau j'ai dû
abandonner mon ego abandonner toute
attente professionnelle lâcher prise
m'en remettre à quelque chose de
supérieur et au moment où j'ai fait ça
ça ça s'est produit alors je savais que
je ne pouvais plus vivre la même vie à
partir de ce moment-là et 3 mois plus
tard j'ai eu ce rôle dans cette série et
ma vie a changé ça c'était il y a 5 ans
c'était il y a 5 an c'est incroyable et
vous étiez partis pour tourner un ou
deux épisodes et on en est à la 4e
saison qui est en train d'être tourné en
ce moment et donc cette saison 3 qui
arrive sur les plateformes sur sur
Netflix et les deux premiers épisodes
donc qui seront diffusés au Grand Rex au
Grand Rex et vous y serez donc demain
c'est ça et dimanche et dans 150 cinéma
en France Merci beaucoup pour attend
d'être venu sur le plateau de P ce soir
voilà si vous connaissez la série en
tout cas vous pouvez la regarder sur sur
sur Netflix notamment et C8 également
diffuser les des épisodes l'année
dernière c'est ça Isabelle oui au moins
les deux premières saisons et la trè
saison arrive à Noël sur Mirac c'est le
financement aussi hein oui le miracle
c'est le financement effectivement c'est
parti raconter en mot c'est
participation chacun participe
crowdfunding et ils ont obtenu 1 million
1700000 quelque chose comme ça
d oui plus de 40 millions en financement
participatif à ce jour c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable inexplicable merci
beaucoup tout cas d'être venu
aujourd'hui et on vous souhaite beaucoup
de
succès que le succès continue merci
beaucoup Jonathan R